we wake up in the morning and special
keep me going
we are out how do you feel good yeah
look at that that's a relaxed Nina I
don't know sometimes you just don't know
[Music]
all right belief nation happy third last
day of our trip
you sleep okay except a lot all right
high five for session a lot I like it
today is our day at sea not quite sure
we're doing yet today we have a couples
massage what's happening at noon
that was Nina's birthday present happy
birthday Nina if you didn't already
leave me a happy birthday leaving the
comments below
she'll appreciate that and we have to
make a bunch of videos I need to make
videos for the channel for you guys so
see how many I can record today and then
apart from that I don't know we'll see
right now right into breakfast and I get
some good food and then we'll plan our
day
[Music]
donut hashbrown like [ __ ] bus sounds and
boot who is Nina's breakfast first round
what's what's in the bowl kanji what
flavor today
beep kanji the bananas in the make your
own music
[Music]
did you see the doughnuts the doughnuts
are crazy how'd you sleep last night
when we called you you were still
sleeping we know my breakfast was
basically the same my dad seemed on up
that same chocolate
I had fruit and then I had cereal all
you're missing is coffee the donuts are
crazy dude three doughnuts are itchy Wow
all right breakfast done Tina got some
extra hot water hot water to take to the
room and now we're gonna head back and
we need to get a video to Christina to
edit be SAP so you guys gave us a bunch
of would you rather questions I answer
and so we're gonna go to the cabin she
would you give us the question all right
done filming for now got three videos
done longer videos that was fun had tons
of interruptions while making it so
multiple takes but that's what happens
you got to be prepared for it this was
my setup so let me show you we sat on
that couch there that's where I filmed
and then this is what I was looking at
the table with a garbage can on top of
it in a tray and three or four books and
then a battery holder that could I could
leave my phone up against and that's how
we make that's how we make content guys
you make use of what you have anyway we
are coming up on noon which means we got
to go upstairs and get our deep-tissue
birthday massage
we are excited he was especially excited
she's probably gonna pass out okay good
good good to know that we're gonna go
have fun to relax and probably not film
much because I'll be enjoying my massage
[Music]
we are out how do you feel good look at
that that's a relaxed Nina did you fall
asleep almost no it was good it was good
I enjoyed hurt it hurt at some times
this very deep tissue water pressure
yeah it cracked
okay back shoulder I wanted some of the
jump on my back and crack and it felt
like it definitely needed the crack but
they ended up having us face each other
and then they we had were blindfolded
and they made us whole teens at the end
that's how we woke up how often do you
go for massages Nena not a lot she she
asked me was lost on my way and I said
six months or so which is a toe that's
not enough you got to go once a month to
loosen your muscles anyway that was fine
happy birthday Nina we're gonna go get
some lunch it's lunchtime
[Music]
I'm having some creamy pasta Nina's
getting ooh shrimp and mussels and
chicken that's a lot of protein there
how's my pasta nice okay that's enough
your birthday was yesterday any man not
today hello Nina and what are you round
two for Nina some yummy pasta looks
exactly like what I just had not whole
wheat though Nina's going all out on
dessert here no this is just coconut
round
Jeremy soup I don't know what that is
getting it all in on the last day on the
ship huh okay lunch is done almost I
gotta take my candy back I'm gonna head
back to the cabin and film some more
videos for the channel for you guys
while Nina finishes up her lunch Shiloh
the fam
all right got some good filming done
finished all my 7-way series still have
a whole bunch of in spresso that ending
to film so I don't know let's figure out
the time to do that I realize that I
have not been around the boat at all
I've not taken a single tour and we're
on our last day so Nina and I are going
to walk the boat ensue we discover walk
the boat walk walk walk the boat and
rock the boat
[Music]
[Music]
all right it is time to go for our last
dinner on board the boat crazy face
painting happening there
maybe I got something special to Nina's
now Chinese look at that face painting
just going last in there on the boat
[Music]
there's a lot of good stuff here today
blueberry soup mushroom soup maybe the
spring roll chilled shrimp and chilled
trim that launches him that might have
five starters that's crazy
I'm sure he's I don't know gotta figure
out the country's and still at the
starters
dinner is done Nina's full yeah we made
a lot nicer half of my entree I eat a
lot I had five appetizers and my entire
entree but now we're going back to the
room why what are we gonna do
pack pack we have to pack all of our
clothes so can you tomorrow
Nina's thought of the evening is I don't
know this sometimes you just don't know
that's the message
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's not packing if you don't have
packing food one last trip to the
ice-cream counter mmm vanilla ice cream
caramel sauce jelly beans Reese's Pieces
Nina got a macadamia nut cookie and we
got some fruit
chow down on as well all right let's get
packing let's get packing it's almost
midnight we are packed we are ready to
go tomorrow morning wake up get off the
boat go to our hotel and see Miami got
one day my name before then waking up
the next day and flying home to Toronto
we're gonna take you guys on a journey
with us hopefully you're having fun
joining us on our Caribbean trip we
believe in you we hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
when where it is much love we'll see you
soon